foreign
[Music]
coming up on FYI have the government
gone back on their promise to reduce the
use of coal to tackle climate change
[Music]
and we hit the ice to meet a world
champion of inclusive ice skating
foreign
this is FYI the Weekly News show where
we bring you all the latest info on the
big stories and one of the big stories
this week has been the future of a
controversial new combine in Cumbria
Cole is a fossil fuel which one born
releases gases into the atmosphere that
can cause climate change
so the government promised that the use
of calling the UK would be phased out by
2024. last year I was invited to the
kids climate press conference hosted by
then prime minister Boris Johnson I
decided to put him on the spot remember
this
um I just wanted to ask a really quick
question whether you're still going to
support new coal mines being created in
the UK
coal mines
to continue our progress towards
zero a zero carbon future and that's our
that's our approach but the government
has
jambria will go ahead but there have
been mixed views about the decision
Braden went to Cumbria to meet with
locals who remember the area as a coal
mining community and to hear what
today's generation think
[Music]
this is Whitehaven and in the short time
I've been here I've learned that not
everyone is happy like a lot of places
in the country adults are struggling to
find work and Rising costs of food and
fuel means money is tight but it wasn't
always like this many years ago a lot of
the people here used to work in the
local coal mines there was plenty of
work but they were closed down long
before any of ozlot were born coal was
really popular it was mainly used for
fires in homes and power stations but
using Coal also produces smog
and it releases gases into the
atmosphere that trap heat leading to
climate change
so why has the government considered
allowing a new Coal Mine to be built
right here in Whitehaven
well the government says it will create
much needed jobs in the area and the
call will be sold off and make money for
the country
the call will be used to create steel to
make things like wind turbines
and that's a twist
so what do the locals think I was born
and brought up in a pit Village called
lauka I'm against it because of the
environmental issues but actually Pro
because it will bring jobs to the area
and I'd like to see
some old industry coming back to the
area really it's probably best out we
move away from this sort of
energy resource even though it would
boost the economy in the area if you
look back in the past at how the coal
mine worked in this area it wasn't only
bad for the environment it was also bad
for individuals working in those
conditions
in a sky kids documentary in your hands
honey reported on her concerns about
plans for the coal mine near her home in
Kendall
I just think it's crazy coal is very
damaging for the environment it causes
pollution and releases carbon into the
atmosphere so the argument is that it
will obviously help create loads and
more jobs and will help make things like
wind turbines so there are benefits then
right yeah I think there are a lot of
benefits but I think the benefits for
this coal mine are really unsustainable
and other Alternatives would provide
jobs for the future
thanks Braden well speaking of the
environment our friend anishwa has
landed himself in the Guinness Book of
World Records for the youngest
documentary presenter the seven-year-old
environmentalists presented the sky kids
climate crisis documentary cop 27 sits
us to save our planet hi anishwa hi
well let's start off by saying
congratulations I mean how does it feel
to be a world record breaker well I'm
feeling very exciting and I want to say
thank you to Sky Kids for giving me this
opportunity and I really hope they'll
Inspire more children like me save the
planet that is absolutely amazing and
what advice would you give to anyone who
wants to save our planet never think
you're too young or too old to make a
difference to our planet well I agree
with you completely and you're doing
such an amazing job so thank you so much
for speaking to us anishwa bye bye
now we've heard about coal mines in the
UK but what about the rest of the world
well here's Romney who lives in
Australia the world's second biggest
chord producer
welcome to my home Sydney Australia
I love everything about our planet
especially the incredible marine life we
share it with
whenever I go for a surf dive or even a
swim and make sure to look out for
rubbish in case it hurts any marine life
well pretty good here in Australia but
there are other things we need to work
on
[Music]
my country is the world's second biggest
producer of coal we dig it up and
explored it overseas it's mainly used by
power stations that burn cold heat water
creating steam that power turbines which
produces electricity
coal is a fossil fuel releasing the very
gases into the atmosphere that lead to
climate change
despite pressure to stop producing coal
Australia refuses but things are
changing
I'm about to take a flight to examine
something so huge that we have to use a
helicopter to see all of it
we're taking off really close to where
we need to go to use the minimum amount
of fuel what we're about to see is
awesome
this is the country's largest Hall of
farm producing huge amounts of
electricity generated by the sun's
powerful rays
I'm flying over Darlington Point solar
farm
here they're oversee nearly 1 million
solar panels
this facility has the ability
[Music]
every single year a hundred and ten
thousand homes is about the same as a
city the size of Plymouth in the UK this
produces no carbon dioxide at all it's a
state-of-the-art facility that you know
is really leading the way in terms of
innovation for what we can do all across
the planet
and solar energy is about to get bigger
in Australia a lot bigger construction
is about to begin on the world's largest
solar farm with up to 28 million solar
panels
the energy it creates will be sold and
exported to Singapore using a giant
cable this is the future exporting green
energy to countries that don't have the
land for solar Farms like Australia does
coming here I actually realized how
advanced our technology is I feel really
hopeful towards our future and how far
this technology can go
now I know that people are really
putting in the work and trying to make
this world a better place for
generations and generations to come
[Music]
here's a story that got our attention
Prince William's godmother Lady Susan
Hussey was forced to step down from her
job in the palace because of racist
remarks she made it was reported that
lady Hussey repeatedly asked and Rosie
Fulani the head of a British charity
about her background and where she was
really from in response the Prime
Minister Rishi sunak said that the UK
has made progress in tackling racism but
the job is never done whenever we see it
we must confront it and it's right that
we continually learn the lessons and
move to a better future time for you to
get your shot on this
the first places in the country also
home to the famous Camden Nook Market
where we'll hear from an FYI News Club
at my old school Elena Palmer Primary
School
[Music]
racism is someone bullying you
physically or verbally to do with your
ethnicity or color of your skin I think
sometimes it's learn if their parents
have like particular views and then they
carry it on yeah I mean it could be like
they're having a hard home life and they
take it out in that way older people
when they were younger they didn't get
taught about this stuff in the school so
they definitely need to be taught about
it if my friend was saying racist things
I'd be like what are you doing why are
you saying these really rude things to
other people this is not right I don't
think
um if they experienced that they would
enjoy it so why should they do that I'd
probably tell a teacher or someone like
that they trust in the eye test yeah
it's always best to because if you don't
it will get even worse and then it will
be a big problem if I saw something
racist on social media I would go tell
my mother and then she can report it to
the police we should stand up against it
because it is not good and we don't want
it to happen
like us you've probably heard in the
news that thousands of workers are or
are planning on taking strike action
that means that they won't be going into
work on certain dates we're talking
train drivers nurses ambulance workers
lawyers postal and Airport staff for
example and teachers and waste
collection workers in Scotland all went
on strike and more strikes are being
planned over the Christmas period a
strike is usually in protest over
something they think is unfair but it's
going to make things really difficult
for lots of us over Christmas however
ambulance workers say they will attend
life-threatening emergencies
so we've been looking into why this is
happening the strikes are over how much
people are being paid many workers
believe they should be getting more as
food clothes electricity gas and petrol
become more expensive many workers say
they don't want to strike but few as if
as a lost Resort as talks of their
employers aren't really getting anywhere
unless an agreement on cellular risers
are reached we can expect a lot of
disruption over the coming weeks at
train stations airports hospitals and
schools
[Music]
it's nearly Christmas which means
Christmas markets lights and of course
ice skating can you ice skate yeah but I
think we live
same well we met someone who believes
that everyone should have the
opportunity to dance on ice and she just
won gold at the inclusive World ice
skating championships this is Teddy's
world
foreign
[Music]
hi I'm Teddy and I'm a world champion
and inclusive ice skating
[Music]
it's not much different from normal
skating except the rules are relaxed a
bit and you're a bit more free to do
what you want
I am autistic and I have ADHD which
means that my brain works differently so
I don't like loads of people around me I
don't like Collide noises things that
are like out of order and I don't like
things that are Out Of Tune and stuff
nice crossovers
that's it
hit the front
ice skating sort of counts me dying and
made me feel a bit more free to do what
I wanted
foreign
what clothes you want to do wearing your
teal of course and for other people it
can be having no music or and or having
a guide on the ice with them
whatever works for you I have been
scareding since I was four it's
basically been as far as long as I
remember and then spin
and an inclusive skating everybody's
friendlier whenever you're you've done
your routine everybody's like
and encourages you I have a lot of
medals I have two gold ones and one
bronze one and if you ask me I would
think it's rose gold but apparently it
is bronze just there's a lot of them and
it's hard to keep track of them all
but
okay
[Music]
foreign
now if you want to report your stories
for FYI head to our webpage for more
details or even better get your teachers
to set up an FYI News Club at your
school
now are you like us gearing up for
Christmas but how can we make the
festive season a bit more
environmentally friendly well we are
some FYI news club members for their
tips for a Greener Christmas
[Music]
you can make Christmas decorations out
of recycled paper like books and
magazines
put yourself in charge of recycling on
Christmas day so as many things as
possible can be recycled ask all your
family to save their Christmas cards and
then you can use the designs on the
front covers as gift tags for next
year's presents you can use LED lights
instead of using regular fairy lights if
they use much less energy when Christmas
is over make yourself a New Year's
resolution and find out as much as you
can about climate change and the
environment
and it's not just Greener decorations
check out these new inclusive Christmas
ornaments they were inspired by 10 year
old Sophia who asked her mum why there
were no black angel or elf decorations
on their Christmas tree
they now make loads of different
ornaments like these father Christmases
so everyone can feel more included
[Music]
well that's all the info we have for you
this week see you next time bye
[Music]